-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
According to reports,
President Biden has yet to hav
a medical checkup
since taking office,
but only because the docto
has been too busy
treating bite wounds.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Bide
has yet to have a medical
checkup since taking office.
Alright, let's relax.
It's been four months.
Besides, at his age,
a medical checkup is just
you show up, you pass.
McDonald's will release
new McCafé cups later this yea
that include
vaccination information
and federal health slogans
to promote vaccine confidence.
Something like,
"What are you worried about?
You eat here."
[ Laughter ]
Federal investigators
have reportedly asked
a former Capitol Hill intern
who dated Florida
Representative Matt Gaetz
to cooperate with their
investigation into allegations
that Gaetz was involved
in sex trafficking
and, apparently, he still
hasn't learned his lesson.
The U.S. Mint
yesterday announced
it will release a new series
of quarters honoring 20 women,
including poet Maya Angelo
and astronaut Dr. Sally Ride
What an honor for those wome
to be bounced into a SOLO cu
at a college party.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA announced yesterda
that teenagers
from 12 to 15 years old can ge
the Pfizer coronavirus vaccine
but only if they
can figure out how
to sign up for an appointmen
on the Inter--
Oh, and they're all signed up.
Okay.
The New York Post publishe
a list yesterday
of the "The 7 craziest,
over-the-top things"
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
has purchased.
Coming in at number 1,
a comb.
[ Laughter ]
NBC announced yesterday
it would not air
next year's Golden Globes,
but only to make room
for their newest program..
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks added a new
strawberry funnel cake
frappuccino to its menu today,
which features strawberry puré
and pieces of powdered sugar
funnel cake,
all for the low, low price
of your foot.
[ Laughter ]
Actress Gwyneth Paltrow
revealed, in a new interview
that, every night,
during the coronavirus pandemic,
she would drink
two quinoa whiskey cocktails
Stars!
They're just like
nobody.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the best way
to regain your smell
after having the coronavirus i
to sniff at least four
different odors twice a da
for several months
or, ladies,
just move in with him.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a woman in Italy
was released from the hospital
over the weekend,
after she was mistakenly given
six doses of the
Pfizer coronavirus vaccine
Well, she wasn't released,
so much as she blasted
through the nearest wall.
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.